hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut ihr habt gemerkt auf
dem kanal soll es mal wieder so einen
kleinen umschwung geben bis der neue
energie muss rein und ich habe mir
gedacht was eigentlich ganz cool wäre
wenn wir wieder so ganz back to the
roots gehen und ich quasi wieder ein
intro benutze ihr könnt euch sicherlich
alle noch an dieses intro oder
[Musik]
dieses intro weg das wurde so lange mit
mir identifiziert gerade dieser song
dazu gut es gab auf youtube ein video wo
es rein um diesen song ging also der
standard alex wie in trogen und das
hatte 300.000 aufruft oder so also
wirklich cars komischerweise wurde das
irgendwie gelöscht aus welchen gründen
auch immer wahrscheinlich lizenz mäßig
nicht ganz korrekt gewesen ich habe aber
die lizenz für diesen song und deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht beauftrage ich mal
drei bis vier pfeiler creator mir ein
neues geiles intro zu basteln ich kann
nämlich glücklicherweise sagen dieses
video entsteht ein freundlicher
zusammenarbeit mit taiwan die leute die
eigentlich keine ahnung haben was wir
eigentlich ist ich zeige es euch mal
kurz und zwar befinden wir uns hier auf
fifa.com bzw fire.de also man kann das
ganze auch auf deutsch stellen ihr könnt
sehen hier sind super super viele
anzeigen angebote und ich musste mich
haben wir auch schon auf privat genutzt
was heißt privat also für youtube
irgendwie grafiken sonst war es man kann
hier eigentlich sämtliche
dienstleistungen kaufen egal ob es jetzt
ein youtube video ist was geschnitten
werden mussten youtube intro irgendwas
mit photoshop bearbeitet werden muss auf
fiber sind super super viele kreative
leute die zum teil so was auch
hauptberuflich machen wir kunden wie
mich content zu editieren zu erstellen
und deswegen freue ich mich erstens sehr
auf die kooperation dass es geklappt hat
und zweitens auf ein hoffentlich neue
schools and roam ihr könnt ihr ganz easy
in viele verschiedene kategorien gehen
und genau das passende für euch finden
es gibt eigentlich alles videoanimation
auch interessant programmierung und
technik ja das kann ich jetzt weniger
gebrauchen aber ich denke mal der eine
oder andere von euch schaut herein ich
habe mir zwei watt ist rausgesucht der
eine bekommt 10 euro von mir von ihm
droht er will heute auch nicht mehr der
andere 50 euro und dann haben wir ein
mit 100 und 1 mit etwas mehr als 100
euro und dann bin ich mal gespannt was
darum kommt ich werde natürlich mein
kanal mit schicken und auch diesen song
also hätte apple
ich weiß bis heute nicht den genauen
text davon haben wir einfach mal was
draus machen haben wir auch schon
unseren ersten creator der möchte für
einen standard youtube intro 13 eur 51
und das kaufe ich jetzt einfach mal
geben ein bisschen input dann bin ich
mal gespannt man muss aber ganz klar
sagen da kann ich jetzt nicht allzu viel
erwarten dass wir vielleicht ein
template sein und man muss auch sagen so
ein ganzes youtube-video zu animieren
und so weiter das ist auch schon aufwand
deswegen denke ich mal er so man muss
doch schon 50 60 70 80 100 euro in die
hand nehmen das ist geil wird ich habe
beifall war echt bis auf wenige
ausnahmen nur positive erfahrungen
gemacht deswegen let's go
check out konfirmand dem habe ich jetzt
hier danach geschrieben hey einmal
professionell youtuber in der logik von
you into this way you can use this song
bereit zu judith okay dann der song
pipapo ok fertig und order starten bin
ich mal gespannt was als rumkommt weiter
geht es als nächstes habe ich den
kollegen hier den werde ich jetzt 100
euro bezahlen also das ist schon eine
menge kleiner fun fact ich glaube für
das youtube intro was viele von euch
noch kennen habe ich damals so 50 euro
bezahlt es war jetzt auch nicht so
aufwendig und vielleicht fand es auch
ein bisschen mehr ich muss sagen ich
weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau wer hier
ist eigentlich mein favorit schaut euch
das mal an was ihr hier macht man kann
ja nie sie auch mal so ein paar sneak
peeks deren arbeit sich anschauen und
das sei nicht weiß aus
[Musik]
wer jetzt noch ein bisschen teurer 135
euro und dann einen der liegt so bei 50
die werde ich jetzt beide noch bestellen
und dann bin ich mal gespannt auf die
resultate okay leute da sind wir auch
schon zwei drei tage sind vergangen und
alle infos wurden natürlich geliefert
ich bin super gespannt und ich hoffe er
wird geiler shit dabei sein zu sagen wir
fangen mit dem günstigsten an das wird
euch mein euro umgerechnet werden 1 für
15 dollar 1 für 60 dollar 1 für 120
dollar und 1 250 dollar ich bin
natürlich ein bisschen nervös okay wir
schauen rein in das günstigste okay ihr
wisst ja mein interesse ist immer mit
dabei gewesen deswegen let's go war das
günstigste auf die plätze fertig los
[Musik]
okay noch mal ganz kurz hier am anfang
halten wir mal fest wer hat eigentlich
nur ein paar der neuesten videos von mir
genommen da ausschnitte rausgeschnitten
dass so ein bisschen zusammen gebastelt
mit übergängen und am ende kommt dann
hier dass alex wie genau das ist das
ende da hat er dann auch ein soundeffekt
hinter gelegt der song an sich kam er
von mir da wird auch bei allen introns
gleich sein ich habe die auch darauf
hingewiesen macht man nicht länger als
zehn sekunden bitte weil introns länger
als zehn sekunden das langweilig
zuschauer ich muss sagen für 15 dollar
in ordnung man sieht dass er sich
hingesetzt hat und da ein bisschen mehr
rein gesteckt hat hat man nichts wisst
es erwarten für das geld ich würde mal
so machen dass ich punkte vergeben von 0
bis 10 den preis natürlich
berücksichtige diese sind heute meiner
meinung nach würde ich sagen 7 von 10
punkten verdient ich würde es helfen
nicht verwenden aber für 15 dollar kann
man eigentlich nicht mehr hat bisher
lang halt leider sonst hätte ich
vielleicht doch ein punkt mehr gegeben
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten intro
das hat mich schon 60 dollar gekostet
der sich auf jeden fall an die zeit
gehalten 9 sekunden und jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt was er mir hierfür das geld
gezaubert hat
[Musik]
aber das ging schnell direkt und
hinterher
[Musik]
ja auch auf jeden fall solide das muss
ich kurz anmerken ich habe jeden noch
dieses foto von mir zur verfügung
gestellt weil ich das ganz gerne dann
drin hätte falls sie ein foto mit rein
nehmen möchten erst halbwegs gut
ausgeschnitten also ich muss hier ganz
ehrlich sagen für das geld warte mal
auch hier es ist halt wirklich ziemlich
easy gemacht der mir keine besonders
schwierigen übergänge oder sonst was
auch die designs die schriftart und so
da hat er sich eigentlich keine mühe mit
gegeben ich muss allerdings dazu sagen
ich könnte ihm jetzt schreiben bitte
ändert dass das und das noch was ist mit
im preis inklusive ist nur schwierig so
vom grund dingen her ist es auf jeden
fall auch in ordnung ich würde hier
sagen weil 60 dollar gekostet hat sechs
von zehn punkte als leistung beim ersten
intro 15 dollar vielleicht ein bisschen
besser aber gut so und jetzt kommen wir
zu den teureren intros auf die ich sehr
schätze und da bin ich mir sicher die
haben geilen stoff geliefert fangen wir
mal mit ihm hier an das ganze hat mich
hier 120 dollar gekostet hat mir noch
nach geschrieben hätte alex hier ist ein
intro ich denke dieser intro style ist
perfekt mit dem kompatibel was du machst
und der musik und ich bin sehr happy mit
dem ergebnis ich hoffe du magst es auch
anschauen wer da mal rein was ich aber
vielleicht noch ganz kurz dazu sagen
muss wenn ihr euch irgendwo
professionellen intro anfertigen lasst
ihr kommt niemals mit 120 dollar aus
also da redet man schnell von 56 7 800
ich habe mal für ein intro von mir was
ich letztendlich dann aber nicht benutzt
habe über 1000 euro bezahlt deswegen ist
das echt schon gut okay seit die rallye
ich bin es auch acht sekunden gehts
let's go com gibt mir geilen schütteln
[Musik]
ja einmal noch
also ich muss sagen wer ich dj wäre das
geil wäre das richtig richtig weiß
vielleicht passt es nicht zu 100% zu mir
aber ist es professionell gemacht er hat
sich viel bei gedacht ist sind viele
kleine effekte drin die das ganze
[Musik]
die das ganze echt gut aussehen lassen
es ist halt so was könnte zum beispiel
wenn ich jetzt im club auflegen würde
perfekt laufen die ganze zeit trotzdem
finde ich irgendwie geil es ist halt
schwierig ihr könnt meine kommentare
schreiben wird so nett zu mir passen
oder eher nicht geil gemacht wie gesagt
es soll dann nur die frage passt das zu
100% zu meinem content und so es sieht
ein bisschen aus als wenn ich diese aber
vielleicht kann man ja irgendwann
nochmal bisschen umstrukturieren dann
bin ich halt jetzt dj hiermit meinen
dicken kopfhörern auf passt das ja auch
eigentlich ganz gut okay hier würde ich
acht von zehn punkte geben finde ich auf
jeden fall schon mal echt gut und jetzt
können wir zum nächsten und zum
teuersten 150 dollar hat mich das
gekostet hier haben was auch schon das
letzte intro muss dazu sagen hat mir
auch gesagt wenn ich noch was verändert
haben will sagt bescheid gar kein
problem ich wollte nur nicht reinschauen
einfach damit ich wirklich diese erste
reaktion auch für euch festhalten kann
ja wenn er da noch was ändert dann wenn
ich euch das auf jeden fall später
nochmal ein wir schauen uns das jetzt
erstmal ein weil vielleicht ist es ja so
geil
[Musik]
warte mal kurz also ich habe ihm nicht
gesagt was er war komplett frei und er
hat sich wir halten hier fest ich mache
viel mit so unboxing sachen werde ich
auch weiterhin viel machen allerdings
nicht nur also es werden auch wieder
andere sachen kommen deswegen kann man
hier vielleicht noch überlegen was man
hier noch hin packen könnte leicht
irgendwie was mit essen und so ich muss
aber sagen das sieht echt gut aus war
hier was er da so animiert hat und jetzt
sagt
[Musik]
ohne scheiß leute ich habe noch nie an
so ein intro gedacht in diese richtung
aber geil oder es ist doch geil deswegen
muss ich direkt sagen das gefällt mir
mit abstand von allen am besten und ich
finde die idee dahinter super gerade
hier mit diesem werbeplakat
und dann kommt so geht es nach unten und
da komme ich mein name so einleuchtend
geil ist das nur zehn von zehn ihr könnt
auch gerne in den kommentaren bewerten
ich sag mal ist nur neun von zehn aber
es ist echt super und ich hätte das nie
irgendwo anders für so wenig geld
bekommen wir jetzt hier das muss man
einfach so sagen deswegen bleibt sogar
gerne in die kommentare welches endlich
am besten gefällt und checkt fein raus
ich verlinke euch alles in der video
beschreibung auch gerne direkt die links
zu diesen designern die ich jetzt
verwendet haben wenn ihr da irgendwann
von buchenwald checkt auf jeden fall
feiern ab danke für die nette
kooperation hat echt mega spaß gemacht
wurden ja mal schauen was dann
letztendlich öfter davon in meinen
videos zu sehen sein wird drei leute
dank fürs zuschauen